submission is largely misunderstood like  I can tell you a million stories I've  had girls who are like yeah you're the  man you're in charge and yeah no problem  yeah she's cool she's cool on the jet  she's cool and Dubai she's cool in the  restaurants she's cooling the five stars  she's cooling the lambo the but the  second I say something that she that  she'd half doesn't like then she's like  well you know what that that's the  feminist right so women do this very  well a lot of women flip-flop like if  you trust your man and you really want  to be with him and you really want to  submit to him there's going to be times  they're going to submit in ways you  don't like that's the whole point of it  yeah things you don't want to do